[Music]
this week we got expensive spell salt
bay trouble and Nutella frenzy that's
helping what's easy
you mean this you're fat I want some of
this
Stein news for it let's say meat but
that's all you gotta go to Dubai to go
to a store no they have one in Miami and
he's there in New York yeah sometimes
alright so for our first story there was
this man and in Ibiza Club I've always
wanted to go to Ibiza espana where
people do like a lot of drugs and the
party my friend that went I want to go
my friend that went there told me the
proper experience is you got to go to
one of those foam parties where
everyone's like in a bikini or something
trunks or whatever and you're partying
till 5 a.m. in the morning then
then you go to the beach and you just
sleep there and then you get back up and
you start party and you do hella drugs
so you sleep there and then you wake up
with red like a lobster I wish that was
the ad like come to Ibiza like do hella
drug this is this is the add voice yeah
ok yeah yeah regular old American add
voice sometimes I wish I could do a lot
of drugs still I'm great I'm scared just
get insurance now it's alright yeah
you're fine you exactly give your
medical card what do you call that
insurance I'm just going to go back to
the dark side
all right well just taking here don't go
anywhere yeah you don't need to yeah so
this man he was filmed opening the
champagne bottle that's worth $42,500
you must be rich is there a lot of
minded people why you're so disconnected
from us average poor folks you know I
have a Bitcoin so 42,000 that's like two
bitcoins in December I know dude but my
big ones like that worth those bananas
right now
it dropped like oh yeah not a good day
yes I'm gonna show you guys this video
and watch what happens to this champagne
oh my god later he's all laughing like
but $2,000 so bad if I was that bad mom
and I drop and I had just bought this
and I'm walking out and I slip and I
drop it yeah
they replace it right I doubt it well me
and Nicky one time we got some 99
bananas which is like I don't know some
liquor thing and for her drink thing and
it was like 60 bucks and we're walking
out and and they gave us one of those
they always give you these boxes it's
like Costco and they didn't tape the
bottom so the thing just went right
through and broke on the floor and we're
like oh [ __ ] we gotta go buy another one
and they're like not even we'll replace
it cuz you were still in this did you
buy it yeah we were still in school and
that's their fault if they didn't hit
the bottom yeah do you buy it we already
bought it
oh so you're walking out anyways 99
bananas all over the all I pictured
literal 99 bananas I don't know maybe
it's changes maybe it changes depending
on the price cuz if it was 10 bottles of
Cristal yeah yeah that's true but 45 G's
but I'd be like yo can I get a they
probably don't even have another one in
stock oh yeah what happened they're
speculating that the person who opened
and spilled the champagne is a club
employee because he had a head piece
yeah cuz usually they won't let the
customers pop open the bottle themselves
yeah so he [ __ ] up that's his job loud
so what they're gonna fire him now I
don't know I would
if I paid that much you better believe I
would I'd be like can we get a bunch of
napkins I'd be pulling it up like as
much as I could I would do that you
better believe it did I get the value
every time that's going in your mouth
does it look like the bottle shattered
it just look like everything just
spilled but people were trying to pick
up the bottle just some time to not
waste any more so I feel like they might
have they might have saved a lot of it
might save like told G's worth each
glass is like a couple hundred bucks
maybe a couple thousand oh wow that was
a pretty big bottle does it consider
good though I've never had anything that
was expensive that where I'm like this
is way worth it bud except for I would
say Johnnie Walker Blue is really damn
good and how much is Johnnie Walker it's
like 300 bucks a bottle yeah whose
[ __ ] mom I don't we were supposed to
open when we hit a million and now we've
hit a million on multiple channels and
it's still there three channels yeah we
have like patron Christo we got like
wine or friends like you know they
become partner to a winery they bring
like a bunch of wine and I'm like that's
just gonna sit there like decoration
what's the new Cristal landmark I have
no idea that's it a new one dude don't
hit me when we get the movie made you
know what I want to do is get a boat and
smash that [ __ ] on a boat that's
true
gonna just smash it you know they do
that tradition when you get a brand-new
boat you get off you [ __ ] smash that
drink and you break it all up and in all
the glass goes into the seat yeah I went
to the launch of an aircraft carrier cuz
my whole family's military and [ __ ]
and they they slid it out I mean is this
gigantic thing like bigger than like
three football field miles long miles
long and same [ __ ] they took a big
bottle up it was like big ball at Costco
for ball though they don't do the
expensive [ __ ] when the military's
paying for it yeah they smashed it on
the they'd like actually had like a
mechanism to smash it the glasses on it
kills all the fish
well no they did something with like a
pulley thing where they like swings down
and hits the side and again it was less
cool than that whole life I want to
smash it like I'm about to get in a bar
fight and then [ __ ] ricochets oh oh
oh your face reinventing the boat that's
true see I thought that's why they did
it in the old day to dent the boat or
detestable test the boat seems wrong
yeah I just made that up
that sounds so legit though good job you
should make up facts more because I
really believe you yes I really do that
was the last test so if it had a debt
it's like Oh take it back yeah yeah I
don't want it I like being on the boat
and me like oh god okay here we go
I knew it is it Kurt you designed this
boat like [ __ ] dude should have tested
Titanic then huh
I know yeah too soon yeah you got to do
that joke like 200 more years
oh yeah you gotta wait somebody's
ancestor could have died on them but
probably not cuz they all died so that's
one of my biggest phobias whenever I go
to the store that has [ __ ] that can
break that's really expensive I'm always
like very careful where my limbs aren't
[ __ ] cuz I'm like I don't want to not
gonna be over yeah like we did a story
with that lady
we're just trying to take a selfie in
this art gallery and then she like backs
up and then she like knocks everything
over to the common oh yeah and it just
like broken the curators at that point
if you're in a museum that expensive you
[ __ ] run I would run so hard I've
never ran faster as I like I would run
and start tipping [ __ ] over I don't have
to make it to see the chase so the
Security's already they grabbed the vase
it's the typical supervillain thing like
you can catch me or you can save your
your friends yep I pray next story
so yes zombie seems to be in a little
bit of a pickle with his
wait me no I'm sorry I'm such a guilty
Catholic I was think of me oh okay
why yeah what the [ __ ] yeah you know
yeah what does this meet what do you
mean salt Bay oh so you're known all
over the meet all kinds of me it's
delicious I play that this is that viral
video that went crazy first one the
viral video that went viral dude he owns
his restaurant
oh god eat there he's so cool [ __ ] up
his blade is sold by whenever holy [ __ ]
that's boy oh my god that looks
delicious I've had a knife is but it's
like a carving knife why so fast but if
you're gonna hurt it so fun
this is all part of the show is it yeah
when you gonna eat it does all this oh
please this is why so sexy with it why
is he gonna be David Copperfield about
it he only wears v-necks yeah it has to
trickle off his arm so it gets his
[ __ ] dead skin cells in it yeah
exactly
I feel like he's in the back cutting
holes and [ __ ] the brick he's [ __ ]
whatever it's gonna take to tenderize a
story though he came from a very poor
neighborhood he became like a butcher's
apprentice I like 12 well you can be
from poor neighborhoods still be a
douchebag right you so grew up to be a
[ __ ] me where where did he come from
you know I believe where is he all his
turkeys I want to say don't quote me on
that
yeah what's the pickle so yeah the
pickle here we do there was an article
written on eater and so they were
mentioning how he doesn't use gloves
when he likes when he prepares his meat
and does that show yeah he doesn't use
goat so that's a health code violation
and that's specific well is it in New
York well so that means New York sushi
chefs are wearing gloves and [ __ ] cuz
that'll do a little plastic booty thing
that is so weird like every legit sushi
place I go to there
yeah they have to yeah he also is
wearing a gold watch on his left arm and
so that's also a violation what do they
know that that's it but wait so it has
to be a rubber watch or a stainless
steel no watch nothing you can't food
service workers cannot accessories I
think that even know all this you can
wear cuz it for chips well I mean he's
not finger banging his [ __ ] before it
comes and cuts to me and I really are
there you just said who's hooking me
that's different Tiffany no no I'm
[ __ ] the meat it's different cuz then
after his dicks on it right it gets
grilled or seared so then it gets to
that point where all that all the germs
are dead it's fine so true
and he's tenderizing the meat so it's
fine you like right let me just soaks up
his juices yeah yeah but if he's all up
in his [ __ ] butt and like rubbing
that [ __ ] he didn't wash his hands and
he's all like like oh that's caca
fingers this is really foolproof
you really can't give get past this
logic that article came out he was seen
in his restaurant wearing gloves he
looks like he's about to frickin do some
bike riding or something no this guy can
wear he's like him and Jack Michael some
of the only people that I know who can
wear sunglasses inside and look cool
yeah cuz it works for him for some
reason it does even attractive dude and
I think his confidence like makes him
more attractive you know he's super into
fitness is he there's all kinds of
boxing videos and all kinds of like
weightlifting videos I wonder what he
sounds like when he speaks oh because
he's just he doesn't say he's like a
mime he's like a sexy mind cuz he's
always just movement
maybe he has a [ __ ] up voice it's like
these can also be wearing sunglasses too
because when he takes him off he's like
he's like he's like do you like hear me
today that's why you have to do it like
this because he can't see it
the class has helped them get his
eyesight sure yeah so the Department of
Health is saying that now they're gonna
be investigating investigation worthy
what about like Chinese restaurants I've
met dozens of them they're gonna
investigate the complaint cuz apparently
that's always coming right I hate her
ass rival the unsexy ones yeah the ones
that don't know how to yeah yeah they're
just they don't own feet deep v-necks
yeah but dude if I couldn't get a table
at this place I would do some [ __ ] like
this though to reduce demand see if you
if you create this efficient of downer
you try to shut down the rice business
down get a table I probably can't tell
the difference in point I can rarely
telling people like oh did you notice
the hint of and I'm like no like oh this
one had a hint of chivor oh my I have no
idea - yeah you gotta see me eat I cover
[ __ ] in Tabasco sauce so much I just
can't taste anything other than hot
thing put the shoes on my stands for
like I haven't haven't heard you once
say that you didn't like something in
like for all the times that were you
cannot ask oh yeah yeah you cover things
at damask but I'm fine like a little
hard like the cinnamon roll it's about
the taste there yes so for our last
story this french supermarket had
Nutella on sale and people just went
crazy
they don't have Nutella cool baby France
but usually they come from not on sale
that's Australian wheelchair Ferrera
what the same people have made we're
shaving - no I don't think so that I
know Rachelle would pace it it's Italian
it's but the company is forever because
they have Nutella inside how did you
know that are you chef know this forever
shares delicious
oh man that's why are you all agents are
all
I'm really Jen I'm not a foodie that was
offended yeah I read that comment yeah I
saw you because you're a disgrace I
think if you're Asian and you're not a
foodie then you lose your Asian card
that's how that's how extreme it is so
you could you could look Asian to be
Asian but you're not aging anymore
yeah you're not accepted by the
community know you're ostracized yep
yeah so this sale here usually they
would sell Nutella for about about five
bucks but then they've dropped it to 175
oh [ __ ] oh that's crazy
Ella riots and [ __ ] was it about the
spire I don't know they just put it on
sale yeah it looks like Black Friday you
like you that yeah no this crowd went
crazy on the chocolate hazelnut spread
when it found out that the item was on
sale the French supermarkets selling it
reduce the price of Nutella by 70% about
lady it went from just over five and a
half bucks to the low cost of a dollar
75 wow that's great it's pretty cheap
that's really cheap I wish they just
added random beep sounds like to the
crowd or just cuz that makes it all so
funny maybe they're gonna sell it on
eBay or something we shall develop yeah
I'm so Asian how much how much Nutella
today you are Nutella last like for a
while remember we had in the tell in our
cabinet and we did a video yeah we had
hinter for like a year or two and it
didn't but I probably eat it like every
single day
put on top yeah yeah crazy
what do you use it on what are using I
only use it on like desserts are like I
don't use it like on on my toaster this
is French food tastes so bad they have
to put Nutella man it was man Paris no
no honestly I thought French was gonna
like French food was gonna be like the
best in Europe because it's bad I agree
I was like what the [ __ ] is this you
guys are supposed to be like the
culinary Jean
of Europe who hasn't I think you just
probably we might just have
unsophisticated taste but you just can't
what is this [ __ ]
unsophisticated I don't think I'm not
sophisticated I think I don't like
cheese that smells like feet yeah that
sounds pretty unsophisticated
that's disgusting good Jesus for smelly
feet yeah it is it unsophisticated to
like Kraft macaroni and cheese nope I
don't think so low quality taste did he
say it to your face like a man oh maybe
it was low quality right it's low
quality taste buds low quality
he said low quality taste buds yeah yeah
and I don't okay you got a low quality
taste but if again it was after like
every single meal was Chinese food I was
just like I'm Chinese food out like
please no morning is I college do you
have low quality taste I think there's
something like that like just playing
around saying like you know you only
like the Mexican [ __ ] that i like like
heavy do you think he's watching this I
wasn't playing around serious but he
wasn't what I mean is he wasn't trying
to hurt my feelings okay yeah that's
just how old Asian people show love is
they talk [ __ ] they talk [ __ ] they're
not trying to hurt your feelings and
when you do get hurt - like what the
hell happened they'll call you fat in
front of your face and go why are you so
sad and then they agree they're like oh
yeah because and it's a good
conversation starter yeah that's a thing
I learned the hard way cuz used to get
butthurt well cuz I'm just it's culture
shock for me like I'm not used to that
[ __ ] being said and in that like blunt
you know so then when you have a fee I
like that I have a B I like that but
that's different cuz that's your family
you know family you have that
relationship oh right the aunt thing
right with elderly Asian people or that
if they're older do I like that one yes
they're all of them I like all of them
it doesn't matter the relationship so
they'll tell you very straight forward
in your life oh [ __ ] so you just get one
that doesn't talk she like way your
weird the minute everyone comes over to
start election and you everything is
wrong with their house everything you're
too fat you too
Taal you're too skinny or to this or to
that I'm like damn I don't even know you
but all right
[Music]